good afternoon everybody welcome to this
session hope everybody had a good lunch
I will do my best to keep you awake for
the next hour but I understand how the
post-lunch
doldrums can set in a little bit if I
see you nodding off I'll understand my
name is Kevin pilch I'm a group
engineering manager at Microsoft I've
worked at Microsoft for the last 17 and
a bit years and for most of that time I
worked on kind of a c-sharp IDE team the
team that does things like intellisense
and refactorings and completion and and
all of that sort of thing for the last
six month or so I've been the group
manager for the asp.net core and nav
framework team and so having only been
on that team six months or so I'm not
like super familiar with the content
there to be able to give a whole hour
long talk on my own and so I decided to
kind of fall back on some of my roots
and when I looked through the session
list for NDC I didn't really see
anything tools oriented and so I thought
it was important to kind of talk about
and demonstrate some of the the advances
that have happened in Visual Studio over
the last few years before I get started
can I get a show of hands how many
people use Visual Studio on a regular
basis I assume most of you how many
people are on 2019 already just about
everybody great news all right so I'm
going to show you some stuff that's new
in 2017 some stuff that's new in 2019
some stuff that's been there since 2005
but stuff that I find that a lot of
people don't don't always know about I
have I think eight more slides after
this but the last time I gave this talk
this was the only one we looked at
because I kind of like to stay in a demo
kind of Orion demo mode so I'm gonna
switch over to Visual Studio
we're gonna spend most of the next hour
maybe the whole next hour inside Visual
Studio playing around with some of the
capabilities that are there if anybody
has any questions during feel free to
shout them out I can go off script a
little bit
and we'll we'll see how it goes so
definitely feel free to shout out some
questions so with that I'm gonna exit my
slideshow and the first thing I'm gonna
do is start Visual Studio so when I
click on Visual Studio in 2019 one of
the first things that you see is this
new getting started screen and this
getting started screen has a couple of
things that are interesting about it so
first of all it comes up pretty quickly
that's a deliberate decision we made we
actually show this screen while the rest
of Visual Studio is still loading in the
background invisibly and so while you're
thinking about what it is you want to
get going we're getting ready to do the
next thing and so you can kind of get to
what you're doing a little bit faster
one of the other things we found is that
people who didn't grow up using Visual
Studio I know some of you in the
audience we're talking about you know
starting using BB 3 & B before and maybe
you're used to the visual studio
experience and UI and you know how to
get going but somebody who's relatively
new to coding starts Visual Studio they
get this big screen with 200 menus with
a thousand menu options and they say
what do I do next right and so we wanted
to give people a little bit of a simpler
entry point and so we have this get
started column over here that has
options like clone or check out code and
I can click on that and just click
github and if I've associated my github
account with my visual studio account
then it will go and find all of the
repositories that I own in my github all
the ones that I have contributed to in
the past all the ones that are in
organizations that I'm a member of like
all the asp.net ones so I can kind of
really quickly get in and it will go
ahead and clone that and open it in
Visual Studio so I can get started
working we're not going to do that one
today we're actually gonna go back and
this will be fun because my resolution
is too big to see the back button so
we'll start this again
haven't quite tried with this font setup
before next thing I wanted to show was
kind of the creative new project so we
also revamped the create new project
dialog so this is now kind of a tag
based system and a capability based
system so I can filter to what language
I use over here I can search and there's
a bunch of different tags if I'm doing
cross-platform development I can find
all of the templates that work on
Android for example that are c-sharp
templates with what I have installed
here and of course I can see my recently
used template again we're not going to
do this and hopefully yeah we're gonna
keep start restarting vs we are instead
going to open an existing project that
I've already created and so I'm gonna
say I have it here pinned so this is a
recent list and you can pin things to it
like most jump lists instead because I
want to show you something in the open
solution dialog I'm going to click over
here on open a project or solution I'm
going to find that solution and select
it but before I click open I'm going to
point out this check box down here do
not load projects so this is an option
for people who work with giant solutions
with hundreds of projects who find that
a visual studio uses more memory than
they want to a lot of people used to use
an extension called funnel that is no
longer being maintained but one of the
things that allows you to do is only
load a subset of the projects in your
solution and so we sort of embraced that
and built it in so I can now open a
solution without any loading any of the
projects and you can see it opens pretty
quickly I'll pin solution Explorer over
here and the projects are not loaded
well that's not a particularly useful
way of working but what I can do is I
can right close right click and load
some projects so in this case I'm going
to load this two dependencies that web
project will assume that I don't care
about testing very much so I'll leave
the unit test project unloaded like I'm
an actual software engineer so I don't
care that much about testing I just want
to focus on I'm getting the code written
so this is good but it's kind of a pain
if I have to do this flow every time I
want to start Visual Studio be really
nice and and this is
also a kind of trivial solution with
only two projects in reality I might
have more than that figuring out which
ones I want to have loaded what their
dependencies are that can be kind of
tricky and so if I right-click on the
solution here down at the bottom of the
menu there's a few new options down here
so there's things like load project
dependencies which says of all the
projects that I have loaded so far go
through and load all of their project to
project references so I have kind of all
of the dependency tree down and then I
can do something like save as a solution
filter and so I can create a new file
that is called a solution F s Ln F which
is a human readable file that contains
the lists of projects that I want visual
studio to load and the next time I open
the solution instead of opening the SLN
file I can open the s LNF file and get
back to that state of kind of a partial
partial solution that I want to work
with so that's pretty great for people
that work with with giant solutions
we're not actually going to do that
today I have a pretty trivially small
solution so I'm just gonna go down here
and say load all projects and for the
rest of it we'll work with with all of
the projects so we've talked we so we've
got a solution open now we haven't
looked at any code yet but there's a few
more things I want to point out before
we do one is we kind of revamped the UI
a visual studio a little bit some of its
a little bit subtle but we now custom
draw the window title bar so we no
longer have kind of the standard windows
title bar there most apps do this now it
kind of looks a little bit nicer it also
gives us a few more pixels of real
estate which predict particularly when
I'm projecting at a low resolution and
large fonts I kind of really appreciate
so you can see the menus are kind of
right here along the top row over here
this is the name of the solution most of
the time you can see the whole name of
the solution because the the fonts
aren't quite as big as this and we've
done a bunch of work in the search bar
so if I click ctrl Q I can now search my
code I can search settings I can search
menu bars I can kind of find all the
things that I might do in Visual Studio
directly by clicking into the search box
that's in the title bar
or entering it with ctrl Q along with
kind of the most of you have you are
using 2019 have been using 2017 so
you're familiar with the new installer
that we have that allows you to have
side-by-side installs
so you can have a preview install you
can have a regular install you can have
an enterprise install and a community
install you can have multiple versions
of Visual Studio kind of side-by-side
with each other and that's kind of what
this thing over here says so right now I
have a build that's called the int
preview so this is the internal preview
that we get inside Microsoft and
basically what happens is every time we
produce a bill to visual studio that
passes our CI CD workflow we promote it
to this channel and it shows up and as
an update to all of our internal
engineers the same way that you see
updates in Visual Studio and move the
way that most people in the division
work is they come in in the morning and
they update to last night's build a
visual studio and that's what they use
to build Visual Studio for today so this
is just kind of lets you know if you
have a bunch of those different builds
installed which one you have installed
last thing before we look at some code
this live share button here how many
people know about live share or have
tried it before a few so live share is
something that we previewed for a while
in bs 2019 it's now built in and live
share allows you to do simultaneous
co-editing of your code so you can start
a live share session send a link to
somebody they can join with their visual
studio and they can Co edit the code
with you they can code debug they don't
have to do any kind of work to set up an
environment and they have read/write
access they have a shared terminal you
can connect to BS code and from vs code
and so kind of both people get to use
their environment set up the way that
they want to I heard one kind of really
compelling story where this was
interesting because there was a user who
had vision problems and so they had a
really hard time collaborating with
other people on their on their team
because when they went to the other
person's computer and tried to
investigate a problem with them they
couldn't see anything
on the other person's computer and
conversely when somebody else came to
their computer and looked at it they
couldn't understand what was going on
with screen readers going and with like
highly accessible fonts and that sort of
thing but one of the great things about
live share is that each person gets to
retain their own ID customizations they
get to work the way that they want to
work while still collaborating on a
problem so it's a it's a pretty great
tool it's now kind of included in in vs
so if you work with other people
particularly distributed but not not
even always distributed I'd encourage
you to give live share a try alright
let's look at some code for a little bit
so the first thing I'm going to do I'm
gonna hide solution explorer for a
little bit so we have some more real
estate and this output window
I'm gonna ctrl T and I am going to look
for a method called get github info so
ctrl T also it can be invoked through
control comma this is kind of go to all
go to everything so this index is all of
your types all of your methods all of
your fields all of your files kind of
everything in your solution and lets you
really quickly get to it with this kind
of preview experience so as I click
through I can see different parts of the
code and I can just go ahead and click
enter and I'm there so this is the way
that I get around my code base most of
the time I don't actually spend a lot of
time in solution explorer because the
kind of fuzzy matching search that works
in in go to all is a faster way for me
to get around I just type a few
characters of what I think the method
name might be and I tend to find it so
we're in this method now and things look
a little different than they might have
looked in the past I'm gonna magnify
even more so that people can see this a
little bit but we have a bunch more
colors going on than we had in the past
so you can see oh boy how do I do this
with magnifier you can see method names
are in kind of a brown control flow
keywords are in kind of a purple fields
and parameters are in kind of a navy
blue types are still in our classic teal
that we'd started doing in 2005 but we
kind of are
to give you more ambient information
about what's going on in your code
without having to kind of hover over
something or go to definition or look at
it a couple other points you can see get
github info in the method is null or
empty and underscore repo parser those
are all bold
why are those bold well those are bold
because they are static
so all statics you can kind of tell at a
glance are bold so this is a new color
scheme that we're trying out for c-sharp
you can customize what all of these
customs what all of these colors are I
in tools options if you don't like the
choices that we've made you can set them
up the way that you want to but we want
to kind of make it easier like I said to
see at a glance to provide ambient
information about what's going on in
your code I want to look at this kind of
repo parser thing next and so I'm
actually going to hit f12 to go to
definition on that and we're gonna come
over here and repo parser is a regular
expression and the next thing I want to
look at is the code of this regular
expression so this is a regular
expression I have a compiler background
so I tend to hate regular expressions
I'd personally rather write a parser
than use a regular expression but I
understand that some people use regular
expressions for things and one of the
things I hear is that they could be
pretty tough to write and to remember
what all the syntax is and to figure out
what I've done wrong so if you look at
this regular expression it's no longer
just a brown string there's now a bunch
of different colors in it that's because
Visual Studio the language service now
recognizes methods on regex and match
and a few of those other classes and
knows that those arguments need to be
regular expressions and it has its own
regular expression parser that it then
uses to classify to color the regular
expression content the way that you want
them to be and beyond that if I type one
of these you can now see we pop up
regular expressions specific
intellisense that tells you what this
part of the regular expression does and
gives you if I if I hover over one of
these
let's let's stop zooming for a second if
I if I hover over one of these I get a
whole big description of what this part
of a regular expression does what this
sub expression is grouping constructs
and the same thing happens in other
parts right so if I'm looking at
character classes I get the same thing
and all the help about what I can do
with character groups and ranges and
negative groups and and all of that sort
of thing so a little help for people who
are doing regular expressions we're
looking at adding a few more of these
kind of sub languages that appear in
strings periodically and there's also
kind of a comment based way that you can
have a string variable instead of having
it go directly to the method you can put
a comment on the line before and say hey
the string on the next line is actually
a regular expression so treat it like a
regular expression okay that's regular
expressions next thing I want to add I
want to talk about is a new feature and
completion right intellisense it's kind
of visual studios bread-and-butter
people have been using it for a long
time it's one of the things that were
most famous for and so we don't we we
try not to stand still and kind of rest
on our laurels they're always trying to
improve it a little bit and so one of
the things that we did in es 2019 I
think it was actually in one of the
updates but I forget which one is we now
index types that you don't have usings
for so I'm gonna type service collection
here and you can see to the right of the
screen it has kind of what namespace
that that type comes from and that is
happening because I don't have it using
for that yet but if I go ahead and
commit this in a tell isense
you can see that it goes teal
immediately and we actually added the
using for you so you can just kind of
type things whether you have usings or
not you know we previously had to add
using light bulb that if you remembered
exactly how to spell something you could
add that using now we kind of go ahead
and put those straight into intellisense
right away and do handle the usings for
you keeping an eye on my notes so I
don't I don't forget stuff so going back
to control T
one of the features that we added for
dotnet core projects is that when I use
ctrl T I can now find CS proj files so
let's look for like webbed CS proj so CS
proj files now show up and go to all
similarly they preview just like any
other files do so I can hit enter and
I'm here in this file for dotnet core
and Donna standard projects we basically
treat CS proj files like any other
project in your solution the way you
expect them to be and so I can do things
like find in files and when I find in
files I can see results that came from
CS proj files which is pretty nice if
you're trying to figure out what's going
wrong with your project file if you're
looking for package references and you
don't know which where they are which
project has them which ones don't
they all kind of show up in the find
results now you can also see that the
finding files results looks a lot
different than it used to it used to be
kind of a plain flat text window now
we've reused the same control that it
backs the error list and the find
references results and so you have kind
of a rich tree view where you can group
things you can lock the results so if I
think I want to come back to this set of
find reference or if I'm in files
results I can lock this and then the
next time I invoke find in files it'll
just pop up another instance of that
tool window and so I can just kind of
keep my my historical searches around I
can type some something in here to
filter within those results so if I know
something about one of the results that
I'm looking for I can filter through
those and of course I can navigate
through them with the go to next and go
to previous and that just like in the
error list I can filter to all files all
the open documents or my current
document so that kind of helps with fine
and files one of the other things that's
hard to show in a solution like this
there's also been a lot of performance
work done in finding files so that we
kind of pre index some of the text so
the finance files results should get you
you should be able to get them a lot
faster
than you had before I was speaking
before about find results or find
references and so one of the things
that's interesting about finding
references is that now what am I looking
for down here now if I find references
for something one of the things that I
frequently do when I find references is
if8 through all of the references look
trying to find how something got a
particular value and so I'm looking for
all the places where this thing is
assigned to and it's kind of a pain
because I spend a bunch of time hitting
a fade and looking at each one and
saying no that's just a use of it and so
one of the things we added is this kind
field over here kind column and like
everything in the solution Explorer you
can kind of filter to the unique results
in that so I click this little filter
thing I can uncheck check read and I can
see the one and only place where this
particular property gets assigned is
right here in this location and so if
I'm trying to find out where to set a
breakpoint to find out how a particular
value got into something I can do it
very easily to find this so that's kind
of getting around your code finding
looking at it let's take a look at
changing your code a little bit a little
bit and so I was kind of joking too one
of my teammates earlier this is the part
of my session where I just hit ctrl dot
a bunch of times and we see what all the
IDE can do for you so we're gonna come
back up and talk and look at the top of
this file and so if you look at my
solution Explorer I'm in a project
called dependency flow dot web but I'm
in a namespace here called dependency
flow dot pages and that's because I
renamed my project after I created it it
would regionally didn't have the dot web
on it because I originally didn't even
bother creating a test project when I
decided to create a test project I added
tests and dot web well I like to have my
namespaces match the project names and
the folders that I'm in and so if I
click on this class name now you can see
this little screwdriver over here in the
margin that says Visual Studio has
something it can do to help you out all
right so we have two different
there we have a light bulb icon that
says we think you should change
something this is a suggestion or we
have a tool bot we have a screwdriver
which is a tool Visual Studio has some
tools that can help you change your code
if you want to so in this case I can
hover over that and click on it or I can
hit control dot which has been our way
to invoke smart tags and and light bulbs
for a long time or if you if you have
some muscle memory for from some other
productivity tools we also work with alt
enter now so you can just hit alt enter
and so one of the options here is I can
change the name space so I can move to
different name spaces but I should also
be able to change the name space to
dependency flow doubt web but I don't
see that today so it could be yeah yes
sorry thank you
help from the audience I was I was all
to entering in the wrong place so if I
click on the name space itself and hit
control dot it tells me hey do you want
to change this name space to be the one
that matches your project in folder
structure here and so in this case I'm
not going to do it because it takes a
while but this is kind of one of the
nice things just a little piece of
comfort that you can have coming back
one of the our most frequently asked for
features is a round link and so what we
find is that a lot of people they like
to check in code that uses link because
it makes them look smart to all the
people that they work with but when
they're actually working with their code
when they're debugging something they
find that it's pretty hard to kind of
understand what's going on and so they
like to have for each is where they can
set breakpoints and kind of step through
and so one of the features that we've
built is the make me look smart feature
so I can come over here to this for each
loop and I can hit control dot and I can
say convert this to link and so this has
now changed it from a foreach loop into
a query that has a from a let clause you
probably didn't even know you could
let Klaus write but you can and visual
studio will help you do it
if you change your mind and say you know
I actually want to debug this then I can
control dot I can select it control dot
and I have to be it's a little finicky
you have to be inside these parentheses
but I can control dot and I can say no
actually convert that back to a for each
write so I can go back and forth the two
different ways I can see which one is
easier to understand what's going on for
now I'm going to stick with this one
because I want to show a couple of other
things here I have this explaining
variable I have a little temporary
variable that it kind of helps you know
I want to I want to play around with the
code one of the things that I spend a
lot of time doing and that I really
appreciate the visual studio helps me
with is spending time figuring out what
the code looks like the best so I can
type in code however I want to kind of
get it working as fast as I want and
then I can spend some time playing with
it before I send it out for code review
to say well how do I want this code to
live forever everybody remembers that
you should assume that the person that
maintains your code knows where you live
and it's gonna come find you right so
you want to make sure you do a good job
having code that is easy to understand
and so one of the best ways I find to do
that is to just play with it and look at
it in different forms so let's do that a
little bit here so I can come to this
variable and say well what would it look
like if I didn't have this variable what
if I inline this in the places where it
was used well okay maybe that looks a
little bit simpler let's keep going with
this
what if I control dot again well I have
two consecutive if statements what does
it look like if I put both of them
together okay this might be getting a
little bit complicated I did a CS degree
there was like logic stuff about ORS
I've got an or in here and a less than
and stuff there was something de
Morgan's law I think it was called about
like changing Anne's to ORS I don't
really remember what it looks like but
if I come over here to this and and hit
control dot then visual studio we don't
call it de Morgan's law we just say
replace and with or but we apply
something called de Morgan's law and
change the
or statement and I can look at it and
say well that looks horrible I
definitely don't want to check it in
that way so let me control dot and we'll
go back to the end so here I am in an
ant I got rid of the variable I went to
kind of a combined thing let's see let's
look at this again one of the options I
didn't choose before is the convert to
link with call form I didn't do that
because we hadn't introduced that
temporary variable and so there's not
really a good call form that you can do
there but now that we don't have that
temporary variable I can do this and so
this does the same operation but it does
it to kind of the link methods that
you're used to so it converts it into a
where and a select and there so this is
another way of looking at the code and
so we've seen like five or six different
ways of how this code could work they
all execute the same way they might have
slightly different performance
characteristics whether they allocate
and capture things or not but they all
kind of return the same results and so
you get to kind of very easily look at
all the different ways your code could
be structured and decide which one works
best for you there was a computer
science tooling researcher that I worked
with and I'm drawing a blank at his name
right now but he used to talk about the
idea of refactoring your code and and
kind of refactorings falling into a
couple of different categories and so he
would say summer factorings
are like flossing your teeth right
there's something that you do all the
time they're pretty quick they're pretty
easy but if you don't do them then
things go poorly and you have to do root
canal refactorings right and so one of
the things that Visual Studio has tried
to do has build in a bunch of floss type
or factoring so I can quickly change
things around and look at it and see how
I want my code to look how I think it's
most maintainable I definitely don't
think this is the most maintainable so
I'm gonna fall back to my favorite undo
and I'm gonna go back to kind of where
we started because I think this is a
pretty easy to understand
pretty debuggable set of code for this
yes
mm-hmm standards yeah so so the question
is like well you know this is this is
nice tooling but a lot of teams kind of
have a pre prescribed formats and they
say this is the way that you should do
things right and I I think that's true I
think it's unfortunate I think that a
lot of times there's nuance and what's
the best choice and I think having the
ability to quickly change between things
and see what they look like allows you
to have a richer discussion about which
is the right thing for this time right
if if it was like oh I'm gonna go spend
some time rewriting this code to be the
different way and then we can talk about
it and if we decide that we still want
it the first way then I have to throw
that out and it's kind of wasted time
then you're much less likely to have
that conversation than if you can hit
ctrl dot and say well what about this
way and then you can say well well why
do you prefer the other way and then so
you can kind of have a little bit of a
richer conversation when the actual
effort of changing the code doesn't get
in the way all right let's see where I
am over here oh so we played a bunch
with if statements I wanted to show that
we did the same thing for everyone's
favorite conditional operators also
known as ternary operators so I can come
over here to a ternary operator
conditional operator I hit can hit
control dot and I can invert that and
say well what if it went the other way
around
right so it's a similar sort of thing
where I can just try it see which way I
prefer it I don't have to think about
you know where's the question mark
where's the colon all those things even
when I have crazy code that has nested
conditionals inside of other
conditionals the visual studio kind of
has a parser it knows what the
precedence is it knows how to do that
another thing that I spend far too much
time doing is playing
with argument lists so I have an
argument list over here it's a pretty
long one you know if people are working
with solution Explorer pins then they
can't see what's in this and so wouldn't
it be nice if I had a way of changing
this right so a visual studio now has a
bunch of controlled options that says
well like what have we wrapped all those
to the next line or what if we wrapped
each one and aligned them with the first
one right this is my least favorite
style so what if I instead said indent
every parameter so just start everyone
indented by four all right so again I
can kind of try all of these things or
if my team has a prescribed style for
which way it does it then I can just
find that option and apply it and kind
of quickly get to this point I don't
have to spend a bunch of time
rearranging parameter lists which I
don't know about other people but I find
that I spend far too much time doing
that so next thing I want to look at is
this this count equals zero lying down
here so I'm gonna zoom in again this
count equals zero line and you can see
it's kind of gray it's not actually gray
it's black but it's got a transparency
overlay on it and the reason it's got a
transparency overlay on it is because
that doesn't do anything we're assigning
zero to this this variable but nothing
reads from it after that and so Visual
Studio is kind of telling us there's no
point in doing this assignment so you
can hopefully see for magenta dots
underneath count and a light bulb in the
margin the for magenta dots our visual
studio saying I have a suggestion for
you I have something that you might want
to do I think it's the right thing to do
so it's not a tool it's not as something
you could do if you want to it's I think
it's the right thing to do
my daughter magenta because I changed
the color and tools options by default
people thought magenta was too noisy and
so they're kind of a muted gray dots
underneath something for a suggestion
but I like to see what visual studio is
true is trying to suggest to me
and so I make mine magenta so if I hover
over this or I click on if I hover over
this there we go
or I click on that I get a error message
kind of in this parameter or in this
quick info that says unnecessary
assignment and it says I can hit alt
enter to the ceasing to see what I can
do about it well one of the things I can
do is remove the redundant assignment so
I'm gonna go ahead and remove the
redundant assignment Visual Studio can
delete some code for me that's not a
particularly difficult thing to do but
it just saves me a second while I'm
looking at it kind of within visual
studio zooming back out if I click on
count here highlight references kicks in
and shows me those two places where
count U is used if I use ctrl shift up
down I can kind of navigate between
those places where where a variable is
used and so I don't know how many people
have seen that before but when something
is highlighted because the cursor is on
it ctrl shift up and down allows you to
navigate to it so I was going to do that
with count and so I quickly determined
that these are the only two places where
count exists so you know I'm not gonna
bother logging the value of count it
doesn't look like we use it for anything
so I'm just gonna delete that and now I
get a suggestion up here that says count
is not used anywhere in this method why
don't you go ahead and remove it as long
as it's not part of the public API and
that sounds like a pretty good idea to
me so if I hit ctrl daaad I can change
the signature of this method find count
and say let's remove that guy and this
will go find all the places where that
method is called remove the expression
that called it yes you have to be
careful if those expressions had
side-effects that your program depended
on you just lost those side effects so
you might want to look at source control
and and verify that this is the change
that you want to make but Visual Studio
will help you make it so there we go
we've done kind of a bunch of things
cleaning up code a little bit next thing
did I delete two things
I did there we go
next thing to kind of show a small
quality of life improvement we've had
our factoring called extract interface
since 2005 you can get to its control
our control I or you can get to it with
control dot on the type of a method or a
type and it kind of gives you this
dialog that lets you generate a new file
with a new interface in it we added an
option to just add it to the current
file a lot of people who are doing
something like TDD they might be
building stuff up they might want to
build a whole bunch of stuff up in a
single file and then decide on names and
then kind of explode it out into the set
of files later on and so while they're
in the flow of just generating a bunch
of stuff they want it to all stay in the
same file so now you can do that I
unselected everything let's go ahead and
pick rate limit and I've generated a new
interface that has that method in it and
I updated my class to implement that
interface it's not particularly exciting
and one of the pieces of feedback that
we heard a lot was that's great if I
think of everything up at all at once
but what if I just want to change that
interface well one of the features that
we recently added is this idea that when
I have a member if I hit control dot I
might want to just pull that up and add
it to the interface so I can just hit
pull up and that will generate an
instant or generate that method in the
interface that I have or if I want to be
a little bit more more root-canal ish if
I want to do something a little bit
bigger I can control dot and I can pull
pick this option too with a dot dot dot
that's going to give me a dialog and so
this gives me a list of everything that
I might want to move up to the base type
this works whether or the base type is
in an interface or an abstract class if
you have multiple ones you can pick
which one you're going to move it up to
it has buttons like select all my public
members
and move them all up if you're doing
that to an abstract class that may not
work because they may refer to private
methods that are in this class and so
like once I select select public then I
can click select dependence and Visual
Studio will look at all of the methods
that I have selected and it will find
all the other methods that they call and
it will pick that set of things and kind
of move it all up to a base type so this
allows you to kind of rearrange your
inheritance hierarchy a little bit when
when you need to do that again this is a
little bit more of a kind of invasive
thing it requires a little bit more
thinking it's a little bit more of one
of those root canal refactorings not
quite as much of a floss and so I'm
gonna I'm gonna skip doing that one for
now but let's assume that now I'm done
with this interface I've got it in a
form that I'm happy with now I do want
to move it to another file well I can
just go ahead and say move it to a
different file and pick a name for me
and it does that I can use f12 to get
there once I set focus so I can just pop
over there and see the interface where
it is similarly like one of the things
that happens is maybe the reason I
wanted this interface is because I
wanted to move it to kind of a different
layer in my architecture and so maybe I
don't want this to be in the pages
namespace anymore well then you can kind
of click here or ctrl dot here alt enter
and move to a different namespace and I
get a list of all of the different
namespaces that exist in my project and
I can just kind of go ahead and move it
to whatever namespace I want it to be it
and a couple more to show here in this
kind of vein of alt-enter type things
let's assume that I'm in my startup dot
CS and I am using endpoint routing which
is this great thing that the Ryan added
and James worked on in
in asp.net core and let's assume that I
want to add health checks support as
well well adding health checks means I
need to do another thing with this
endpoints option and so I can kind of
try to remember how to turn this into a
block I can type and open curly and find
the end and type semicolons in the right
place or I can just hit control dot on
this and say you the block body for that
instead or if I have this and I don't
want it I can control dot and I can say
no you know what use an expression body
right so again I can kind of go back and
forth between the two so if I have a if
I want to have a block body and I want
to like hook up health checks or
something then I can say map health
checks to the health URL right and so I
can kind of quickly switch forms between
different things not have to remember
exactly where all those braces and
semicolons and all those things go last
control dot thing I want to show you I'm
going to pop over here to one of the
unit test files we have and I'm gonna
write a new unit test so let's have a
fact public void logging and we're gonna
use mock for this so I'm gonna have a
mock of an ilogger of an incoming model
equals a new oh logger so this is great
except that I have these errors because
mock isn't found and that's because if I
come up here and look at the
dependencies node and I look at the list
of packages that I reference I'm not
actually referencing the mock package
and so at this point you know I could
come in here and right click and say
manage NuGet packages but I don't
actually have to I can click on this I
can control dot and I can just say
install package mock and I'll just say
fine and install the latest version and
so Visual Studio is searching new guide
hopefully my Wi-Fi works well here it
added
using Mach and everything resolved now
those errors go away how did it do this
how like what is what is new guys do or
what is Visual Studio do here we
actually have a service that trolls
through every package on new get not
every package we troll through like the
top thousand most downloaded packages
and we find all the types that exist in
those packages and we build an index of
all of those type names and we ship it
down to Visual Studio and so Visual
Studio looks at that index of all the
types in the top thousand packages and
says I know what package that's in I can
add a package reference for you and so
that's actually exactly what it did if I
double click on this CS proj file
editing just like every other file I can
double click on a CS proj file and have
it open in the editor
some people love that now it's like one
of our most loved features of es 2016 it
was also one of our most hated features
in 2016 a lot of people strongly believe
that double clicking should collapse or
expand their their project files so
there is an option and tools options if
you're one of the people that believes
that it should should expand and
collapse instead of open I I believe in
opening but so Visual Studio went here
and it added this package reference to
mock for us so now we're able to kind of
use things alright I am a little bit
behind time so let's see how quickly we
can go coming over here let's finish
writing this method if I use this kind
of standard not null method one of the
things you can see here is there is a
star beside not null why is there a star
beside not null the reason is that
Visual Studio is using a machine
learning model to predict what are the
most likely things that you're going to
want to use in intellisense the way that
this works is we find I think it's 5,000
projects on github that have a hundred
stars or more and we train a machine
learning model that says these are the
most used members of every type that we
can find in c-sharp we do it for
typescript and Python and C++ and zamel
and I think oh and visual basic and I
think that's all the languages that we
support right now some of those are
still in preview because we're still
tweaking the model data a little bit but
you can kind of get this this machine
learning guidance it's also pretty smart
so if I come in here and say logger if I
play with a string so let's just say
string s equals something right and I
want to say s equals s dot well it finds
the things that I commonly do with a
string in this kind of context right I
might trim it I might to lower it I
might to lower invariant I might take a
substring it also says length which
doesn't make much sense but sometimes
machine learning is a little bit wonky
right sometimes the machines aren't
actually that smart but if I play with a
different context so if instead of doing
an assignment like this if I said if s
dot well then I get an entirely
different set of things that are starred
because the machine learning model takes
the context it says I'm actually I
actually need a boolean I am doing this
in the context of an if statement what
are the most used members of string in
the context of an if statement well it's
a different set than it is in an
assignment and so we got it kind of
different results so this is kind of
some of our first forays into into using
machine learning to help you code more
predict productively as I said we have
kind of a bunch of things that are in
preview there so if I come into tools
options that feature is called Intelli
code should mention the brand name
Intelli code is kind of the brand for
that and so we have a bunch of things
that we're playing with a bunch of
features so one of them is is this idea
of custom models so as well as having a
model trained on on github if you have a
large enterprise code base of your own
with a lot of your own types you can say
hey go ahead and train an addition to
that model for my specific code and I
will point out that when you do this
none of this code this machine learning
code none of this goes to a service and
sends your code to a service it all runs
locally on your machine
there's not a privacy concern where if
you train a model like we're gonna
upload all your code to a juror and keep
it we train the model locally on your
machine it's only for you to kind of use
but anyway there's a bunch of different
different preview things we can do here
one of the ones that I have enabled is
this idea of editor config inference and
so let's take a look at what that is
editor config is a kind of convention
that started and a bunch of open source
projects where I can check a file into
the root of my repo that has some
conventions and so it started editor
configured to find six things it says
like do I use tabs or spaces do I have
new lines at the end of the last line of
my file or not things like that how wide
is a tab but they also said different
editors or different languages you
should extend this file you should put
some more stuff in this file that makes
sense for your language and so a visual
studio kind of went whole hog on that
and so combining kind of editor config
with that in Teleco thing if I
right-click on a solution and I say add
there's an option here that says new
editor config based on Intel akkad and
so if I click that it's gonna take a
little while what it is doing is it is
analyzing all of the code in my solution
and saying what style does this code use
does it use bar or not does it use this
dot or not does it use spaces after
colons and names or not right like what
are all the formatting options what are
all the code style options that this
uses let me generate a file that
codifies that so I can add it to my repo
and I can transfer it along with my
source code to other people who use
tools that are aware of this editor
config file and then I can solve some of
those arguments that you might have with
your team about what is the style
because Visual Studio can go ahead and
tell me what the style is so let's look
for one particular one let's look at the
options around bar right so the machine
learning model has decided that for two
of the three options that visual suit
supports for VAR i like to use bar the
third option doesn't show up maybe
because this code base isn't big enough
for it to form an opinion on that right
so I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna add
that one manually from memory there are
other ways to find these but I happen to
have worked on this feature and I know
this one so I'm gonna add the third one
and I'm gonna come back over here to
incoming tests and you'll see oh I
forgot to mention with the magenta
suggestions earlier they also show up in
this kind of enhanced scroll bar over
here so you can see now I have three
suggestions for three places where I
explicitly refer to a type but my editor
config has said no no no the style in
this code base is to use bar I'm not
going to debate whether bar or not bar
is better I think it's a personal choice
I think you're wrong if you don't choose
to use bar but it's still a personal
choice so I've got this editor config
setup it's great everyone on the team
can use it I can come along now and I
can hit ctrl dot and I can simplify it
great what if this is a big code base
what if this is file is more than 40
lines long and there's a lot of places
where I use bar well one of the things I
can do I'm gonna get rid of this line
and I'm gonna and I'm gonna that's fine
so I've got two of these places now I'm
gonna come back over here to the editor
config and I'm actually going to change
these and say make these a warning if I
can type warning instead of a suggestion
and so I'll do that for all three of
those and I'll come back over here to
this file and so you'll now see these
are green squiggles instead of
suggestions because Visual Studio
understands that our config file in fact
the compiler now understands it and if
you add the right NuGet packages to
enforce some of these style things the
compiler can generate errors or warnings
on your build on your CI if you use the
wrong style some people care very
much about enforcing their style and
want to do that some people prefer to
let it be a suggestion in the IDE I'm
normally a kind of suggestion in the IDE
person but looking at these warnings one
of the other things I wanted to show is
this little marker down here so this is
kind of a file health indicator and so
he says I have zero errors in this file
I have two warnings I can click on that
and it'll take me to the air list and
see what they are but we don't have a
lot of screen real estate and I'd like
to get rid of the air list now please go
away or list so one of the other things
I can do is I can just hit this arrow to
say go to the next one
right so I can navigate between the
warnings or errors in my file very
easily and then I had this little
paintbrush thing over here it gives me
an option to run code cleanup and so I'm
gonna come up here to the top of the
file I'm gonna click that and people who
are observant they noticed that it
didn't fix my warnings but they noticed
that are using disappeared up here well
what's going on well if I click this
little aéreo de air arrow down here I
have the option to configure code
cleanup and if I look at it the default
code cleanup profile is set to do
nothing but remove and sort usings
that's fine but we have the option of a
second profile the reason we do this is
you won't there might be something that
you want to do a thousand times a day
and you want it to be super quick and
you want to be able to trust it right
and so that's what we think of as the
profile one version there might be
something that you do occasionally when
you want to clean up your code right and
so I've set this one up to apply fixes
for a bunch of different style things
and so if I come out of here and instead
of saying run just run code cleanup if I
say run profile too then it fixes all of
those things in this file and I get a
little green checkmark down here that
says I have no issues found in my file
that's great but what if the solution
that I work on has six thousand files do
I have to go to every one and say run
code cleanup well no so on the solution
and project nodes we added in this
analyzing code cleanup menu the option
to run code
clean-up on the whole solution or if you
right-click on a project it'll run it on
the project great what if I'm a command
line person well here's the one command
line part of my demo I can come over
here and I can use dotnet global tools
so I can say dog mad tool install - G
dotnet - format and again if NuGet is
working well and well knew if Wi-Fi is
working well enough to get two new guide
I'll install a global tool and then I
can just come here and say dotnet format
so this is now going to load the
solution it's gonna run formatting on
all the files in my solution and it
changed a couple things so one of the
things that changed is index dot yes ta
CS HTML CSS well let's come back over to
visual studio and find out what it did
so if I find index dot CSS HTML dot C
yes and I right-click on it and I say
compared with unmodified somebody didn't
have an if a space after the R if
statement and so before my tool found
that and fixed it just one thing I
wanted to call out while I'm here in the
diff view it's sort of unrelated but it
is the idea that this diff view is
actually live I can go ahead and change
the code here so let's say I wanted to
change this to be called repository this
is kind of a live de few that edits as I
go if I undo that typing the green and
red go away and it goes back to being an
unmodified line so this is what's
something that I like to use sometimes
just to kind of keep an eye on what have
I actually changed in this file ok
before we went into all the editor
config stuff we were looking at tests so
let's look at tests a little bit more
the last thing I wanted to talk about is
some changes to test Explorer so let's
bring up test Explorer and pin it
because we're gonna spend a little bit
of time looking at it so first thing you
notice test Explorer is horizontal
across the bottom of my screen so we did
a bunch of work
to relay out how tests Explorer works so
that it can work well with a horizontal
layout we also took advantage of that
same control that we have in the air
list and find results and find
references results and a few other
places to populate the air list and so I
get the same kind of columns with
different filters available to them I
get the same automatic search I get the
same great scalability up to hundreds of
thousands of tests and so I can I can
use test Explorer in all of those I got
a nice kind of hierarchical view of
where I have tests and one of the other
things you'll notice is that I already
have results here for tests but I have
an open test result test Explorer yet
one of the reasons for that is it
actually stores the last test result in
your vs folder so when you load a
solution again it can tell you what the
test results were the last time it ran
them so these are kind of stale test
results from before we ran but I can go
ahead and run the test one of the things
that I'll point out is execution and
discovery of tests both now happen
outside of the visual studio process the
discovery used to happen inside BS which
meant that it had to kind of be fairly
serial it was pretty slow they used a
lot of memory it could push the vs
memory up close to the limits if you had
a large solution but now it doesn't run
down a process I'm actually gonna run
that again because I missed my chance to
talk about something that I wanted to
talk about we also have this great set
of icons right though so some are failed
some are waiting to run some are still
in process they're actually executing so
that's what the the little Spinneys are
so there's good visualization about
what's going on during your test run so
I have a test that failed if I come over
here and click on it you can see the new
tests the results details pane over here
and one of the things that we've done
there is it's no longer just a dump of
text so there's some icons there there's
links to stack traces that actually
navigate my personal favorite feature
that the output from your test now
happens in a fixed-width font so if you
use something like X unit that has nice
visualizations of string differences and
points to exactly where something is
different that actually works now
whereas it didn't before and so I can
quickly go ahead and click on this and
fix my test so I click I do that I have
a couple more buttons down here so I can
quickly just say rerun just two failed
tests instead of rerunning everything
and when I do that I get some indication
of what's going on because these tests
are now green these ones are faded not
says the last time these were run they
passed but you've made code changes
since you ran them there's been another
test execution since you ran them so we
don't know if these results are still
valid anymore okay so that's kind of the
basics of the the unit testing stuff two
last super quick things about unit
testing one of the interesting things is
sometimes I don't want to run all the
tests in my solution sometimes I want to
run part of them that can be a pain to
kind of track and manage you know the
new test Explorer window lets you define
how you group things and so that can be
bit can make it easier if you want to
switch up your groupings but it's still
not necessarily what you want and so
let's take these integration tests these
slow ones and we'll right-click on them
and we'll say let's add them to a new
playlist and a new playlist basically
gives me another copy of the test
Explorer window but that is scoped to
just that set of tests and I can save
that into a file let's call these slow
tests and so back here in tests Explorer
you know if I close this this is now an
artifact that travels with my solution
and so I can come over here and click
open playlist and I can get back so I
can configure different subsets of tests
to run and store them as playlist files
and get back to them and lastly we do
the same thing for live unit testing so
a live unit testing is sort of an
implicit playlist
so I can come over here and click start
and use live unit testing and it has its
own window so you can see kind of the
exact state of what's going on with live
unit testing and see all of the tests
across the whole solution instead of
having to use the margin so here we're
waiting to run with live unit testing
and there we've run it I can similarly
like just make a change and live unit
testing will rerun just those failed or
just those change set of tests and it
will immediately update without me even
saving or invoking a test run it'll let
me know what what tests have failed
it'll let me know the code coverage so
this says this is actually covered by a
test that fails other tests are covered
by tests that pass right so this is
these lines are covered by tests that
pass and so live unit testing is kind of
another way that you can get that kind
of ambient sense of what's going on your
code is this code covered is it covered
by passing tests is it covered by
failing tests let my machine do a bunch
of work in the background to just kind
of manage all those tests for me and
tell me how the code I'm writing is
without me having to do it myself all
right I am at 240 so I will not show any
more slides in this session I will end
it here I'll stick around for any
questions that people might have but
thanks very much I hope you enjoyed
seeing a little bit of what Visual
Studio 2019 can do
[Applause]